hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
one of the most central concepts and
claims that is being made
in friedrich nietzsche's genealogy of
morals very early on
in essay one of the work and something
that runs throughout
the rest of nature's works as well
is this notion that there is a
primary form of what he calls valuation
vertong right
giving giving values to things in
relation to each other which is a
distinctively human activity
and that we have lost sight of this and
so
he's using this at the start as a foil
to those
english psychologists who see doing good
things for other people doing things
that are beneficial that help other
people
as then being identified as good because
the utility says no
no that's not the case at all you've
actually
got not just the cart before the horse
but you you don't even have the horse
as a matter of fact you're completely
confused about who's
doing the value judgment it's the person
judging him or herself as
good in relation to other things that
essentially gets things started
and so he tells us that the strong or
the nobles he also uses the word
aristocracy
that that these are the ones who
judge themselves as good in relation to
the others who are not good and they're
just identified as bad
and interestingly nietzsche
is going to turn to language and he's
going to say you've missed out on your
opportunities
to do the kind of historical research
that that would have benefited you
languages go back a very long way and we
do have a lot of
material to work with so he says the
signpost to the right road for me
was the question what was the real
etymological that is you know in terms
of words
significance of the designation for good
coined in the various languages and then
this is the insight that he's drawing
from this i found they all led back
to the same conceptual transformation
that everywhere noble aristocratic in
the social sense
is the basic concept from which good
in the sense of with aristocratic soul
noble with a soul of a high order with a
privileged soul
necessarily developed and so he's saying
that we can find this
in in going back to ancient languages
and we can find this in pretty much
every culture
along with this he says that this rand
parallel
with another development in which common
plebian
low are finally transformed into the
concept bad
and he gives an example of this the
german word schlecht
which is identical with schlicht plain
or simple
he says compare schlechtveg plainly
schlechter ding simply
and originally designated the plain the
common man
as yet with no inculpatory implication
and simply encounter distinction to the
nobility and and he says uh about the
time of the thirty years war
this meaning changed into the one now
customary and he says
with regard to immoral genealogy this is
a fundamental
insight that our language itself
in the past can reveal to us what the
primary evaluation where
good came from in its first
sense so he goes on and he says
um here we go in the majority of
cases these these ancient people would
designate themselves simply by their
superiority
in power as the powerful the masters the
commanders
or the most clearly visible signs of
this for example the rich the possessors
he says they do it also by a typical
character trait which we're going to
talk about
in a moment but there's also a number of
other important linguistic discussions
going on here so we should jump ahead to
chapter 10 of the first essay
he tells us that
[Music]
here we go the basic concept
you know is being displayed and calling
ourselves we noble ones
we good beautiful happy ones
and he says we should not overlook the
almost benevolent
nuances that the greek nobility bestows
on all the words it employs to
distinguish the lower orders from itself
how they're continuously mingled and
sweetened with a kind of pity
consideration and forbearance he says if
you want to designate the common man you
call them
unhappy pitiable and he's got examples
of this delos in greek
de leos poneros moctros you know weak
in the the last sense right um
the last two of which properly designate
the common person as a work slave and
beast and burden
and he also you know talks about how
they they describe
themselves through language of
of beauty carlos right uh
being powerful being able to do that
let's
let's turn that into this this key
character trait that he identifies and
this
really drives home the message i think
he tells us that there we go
they designate themselves by a typical
character trait
and here we actually have several
different concepts that
are being associated and combined with
each other
so what is the character trait they call
themselves
for instance the truthful and this is
uh so above all of the greek nobility
whose mouthpiece is theogonist the the
root of the word coined for this
esthos signifies one who
is who possesses reality who is actual
who is true
then with a subjective turn the true as
the truth
full in this phrase of conceptual
transformation
it becomes a slogan and catchword of the
nobility
and passes over over entirely into the
sense of
noble as distinct from what the lying
common person the clever person the one
who's going to try to get over on you
which is what the agnes takes him to be
and
you know this this is actually quite
important
there's this sense in which the powerful
the good in this sense are more people
are more real than the common
mass and hurt and when we want to think
about this in terms
of truth
right we have to be very careful not to
tie this into something like a truth is
the way things exactly are
he brings up the fact that the ordinary
you know actually not an ordinary that's
the but the the average let's say
noble person probably has no idea what's
really going on in the lives of the
common people
that doesn't mean that they're lacking
truth except
in that sense it's having the truth of
things that
matter things that are important
nietzsche is getting
at and he says that very often they do
get things wrong not just about the
lives of commoners but
even about other noble people or about
themselves but that doesn't prevent them
from being the esthlos
the truthful those who have fuller being
in in this valuation right
he also talks about this valuation
growing
and doing so here we go this is
quite quite good he says it's not
reactive at all
it's it's instead spontaneous and active
it
acts and grows spontaneous it seeks its
opposite only so as to affirm itself
more gratefully and triumphantly its
negative concept
low common bad is only a subsequently
invented pale contrasting image
in relation to its positive basic
content concept
filled with life and passion through and
through right
when the noble mode evaluation like he
says blunders and sins against reality
it only does so in respect to the sphere
with which it's not sufficiently
familiar
against the real knowledge of which it's
guarded itself or some circumstances
it misunderstands the sphere it despises
of the lower orders
right so the the strong
are literally imposing this value
judgment on to the weak you're bad we're
good
and there's room in that for
somebody who is within the class of the
week in the common class to rise
to display themselves as actually having
strength as having nobility of soul as
having
these capacities to enter into the list
and if they survive
they will be the strong right
whereas if they they they don't or if
they never make any move well then
they're obviously the weak and bad
and you can just keep on identifying
them as that
relations with others so the relations
with the
ordinary common people the masters the
strong are exploitative they dominate
they take more than
you know what we would call their fair
share they view it as their fair share
they're not really worried about the
problems
that ordinary people face or if they are
it's going to be
pity descending from on high and daining
to do something about that they don't
view
the weaker as having some sort of claim
upon them
that they could be bound by now
interestingly it's not as if they're all
in one grand conspiracy
to impose this upon the lower classes as
we see like in sci-fi shows
or things like that where there's a lot
of social stratification
they actually fight with each other
quite a lot and they
do other things with each other if you
ever you know think about
homer's nobles in in his stories in the
odyssey and the iliad
and you get a good conception of what
we're talking about
here so again in chapter 10 there's a
great discussion of this
here he tells us here we go
that um
they uh they you know they're sort of
driven by a kind of spontaneity they're
held in check
between equals right interpares
is how he uses the term and
he tells us too that that they they can
have resonte month but they
they let it go it says risantomont if it
should appear in the noble man
consummates and exhausts itself in an
immediate reaction
and therefore does not poison
to be incapable of taking one's enemies
one's accidents even one misdeeds
seriously for very long that is the sign
of the strong full nature
in whom there is an excess of the power
to form
to mold to recuperate and to forget
so you know you can have enemies you can
have rivals as a matter of fact you
probably
need to have them but you don't you
don't
hate them with a hate that goes to the
very depth of your soul
and prompts you to obtain secret revenge
against them
you could say that you know the old
adage revenge is a dish best served cold
that's not what the stronger nobles
think they think well if you're going to
take revenge take it right away you know
make it open make it
make it clear and a little bit later on
in um 11 he says that
here's one thing we shall be the last to
deny he who knows these good men
as and only as enemies knows only evil
enemies
and the same men now this is the nobles
who are held so sternly in check
enterprise by custom respect usage
gratitude
and even more and so let's dwell on that
for a moment custom
respect usage and gratitude there are
more a's
that guide and shape and form
the actions of the noble
in relation to each other if they're
equals
right they could treat each other as
commoners and
thereby you know try to try to shame or
lower
the other person but generally that's
going to be frowned upon
he goes on and he also talks about them
[Music]
displaying mutual suspicion and jealousy
right these are people who
jockey for position who try to one-up
each other that's part of their world
that's part of their
problem they're more interested in that
than they are and the people who
say work for them on their estates
they're going to have rivals they're
going to have enemies they're going to
have conflict
but they can also do something
else which is we would probably say more
positive he says
they show themselves so resourceful in
consideration
self-control delicacy loyalty pride and
friendship towards each other
right so now this is a little bit of an
idealization there because we can all
think of some
rich person who's really a prick right
and doesn't
never learned any of that sort of stuff
and just shows entitlement
towards even their own peers and you
know is regarded as a jerk by everybody
but there is there is this possibility
developing from this abundance of
strength this abundance
of energy this willingness to
get out there and and drive and you know
dominate
it makes it possible for there to be
loyalty pride friendship right
he also talks about self-control these
these are not necessarily people who are
just
indulging their desire to dominate at
every single point
certainly not among their own class now
it's different he says
when we're looking at their relations to
the outsider and here we have to think
of
you know we've got the the strong right
and they have their own
sort of class or whatever you want to
call it in the society
we have the weak the commoners and then
we have those who are outside of that
society
outside of that culture those who he
talks about
uh as you know for example barbarians
uh from the perspective of the the
greeks right
he tells us that all of these nobilities
whether
roman arabian germanic japanese homeric
heroes scandinavian vikings
they all share this need to go out to
the wilderness and fight with somebody
who's different somebody who's not of
their group and he says
when that happens all bets are off
so i'll just read you this this passage
once they go outside where the strange
the stranger the alien the femt right
is found they are not much better than
uncaged beasts of prey
there they savor a freedom from all
social constraints
they compensate themselves in the
wilderness for the tension engendered by
protracted confinement
and enclosure within the piece of
society they go back to the innocent
conscience of the beast of prey as
triumphant monsters
who perhaps emerge from a disgusting
procession of murder
arson rape and torture exhilarated an
undisturbed
soul as if it was no more than a
student's prank convinced they have
provided the poets with a lot more
material for song
and praise and he talks about this as
the beast of prey the splendid blonde
beast prowling about
in search of spoil and victory and
here's where he talks about all these
different nobilities
he says it's the noble races that are
left behind them the concept barbarian
wherever they have gone and i think that
there's probably
something to this and i would actually
say that you know nietzsche's notion of
noble races
is probably way too too shrunken if we
look at world history we do see this
dynamic playing itself out
on pretty much every continent um
you know whether or not this is an
accurate depiction of
how things played out in history all the
time you know we can we can put that
aside
he does actually bring up pericles
funeral
oration and it's well worth
thinking about this he says pericles
specifically
commends the rathumia of the
athenians this this you know ease of
mind
this willingness to engage in
thematic activities in relation to
others and so that's you know another
sort of wrinkle to this so we've got
this valuation
that not only makes the
nobles the good good in the sense of the
powerful those who can
exert themselves those who have true
existence and
exist in relation to each other but also
makes the commoners the bad
the you know ordinary the weak the
people who can't assert themselves
but it's also oriented towards the
outsider
as well and sometimes you can find
societies where the commoners
are treated as if they're outsiders like
you know the spartans with their
their the prime example there so there's
this is the primary evaluation according
to nietzsche
he's not actually saying we should all
revert to this that this would be an
awesome thing but he is saying that this
is where the concept of good
first makes its appearance in
the languages of human beings and the
way their societies
stratify themselves stratify themselves
through the agency of those who
become the ones on top
you